chuckle what is more important in being
successful at achieving your goals
nature or nurture okay so this is the
classic question of nature versus
nurture and in my opinion it's neither
then my whole life I've seen people from
every different strata in a SEAL Teams
you had everybody you had
Ivy League kids with a silver spoon and
you had former gangbangers and hoodrats
and the same time you had prep school
kids and kids from blue-collar families
and everybody in between there was kids
with the big strong families that were
really really close he had kids with no
families kids that were pampered and
kids that were abused everything we had
everything and in all of those different
groups there were some people that were
successful and got the job done and some
people that were unsuccessful and
couldn't get it done and in working with
businesses now I see the same thing
people from every walk of life from the
bottom to the top and I've seen every
type of those different types of people
be successful so to me it's not about
nature or nurture it's about choice the
people that are successful decide they
are going to be successful
they make that choice and they make
other choices they decide to study hard
they choose to work hard they choose to
be the first person to get to work and
the last person to go home they choose
to take on the hard jobs and take on the
challenges they decide that they're
gonna lead when no one else will
they choose who they're gonna hang
around with and be associated with and
they choose who they're going to emulate
these people choose to become who they
want to become
they aren't inhibited by nature or
nurture they overcome both and I'll tell
you something else it's never too late
to make that choice you're never too old
to decide where you're going to focus
your efforts and push to make the most
out of every situation so to me it's not
about what you've been through and where
you were it's about where you're going
and it's about the choices that you make
it's about choosing choose to make
yourself smarter and stronger and
healthier choose to workout and study
and eat good food and keep your mind
clean don't let nature or nurture make
you choose to make yourself